these are crazy chaotic times and what
are we supposed to do when our whole
lives have been disrupted mentally
emotionally physically spiritually
financially right so what are you
supposed to do to stay on track how do
you really get the most out of your day
how do you earn more money how do you
stay healthier how do you have a better
relationship in the midst of all that
chaos so first a farmers do you have a
daily routine do you have a morning
routine do you have an afternoon routine
you have an evening routine now that
most of the world is at home most people
do not have a routine or they have
limper they're not deliberately focusing
on how to be maximally productive every
single moment of every day and since
your greatest asset is time the question
is are you using time well there is no
such thing as time management no such
thing the only thing you can do is
manage what you do in time and when you
manage what you do in time you're either
gonna be highly productive or you're
gonna waste a lot of time so what do you
do when you wake up what do you do when
you first wake up let me share a couple
things with you number one all right
when you first wake up that is your time
to set the tone for the day so are you
getting up and going and doing something
productive or unproductive what about
starting off every day as you wake up as
you open your eyes why not start with a
gratitude practice what are you grateful
for if you woke up this morning and you
put your feet on the floor you can be
grateful for being alive do you know
what that does to your brain what does
it do to your brain when you are
grateful and you think of something your
rig before you're actually releasing the
neuro chemicals of whatever it is that
you're grateful for so if you aren't
grateful for your health if you're
grateful
family if you're grateful for being
alive you're releasing those neuro
chemicals of gratitude which does what
makes you feel good so every morning I
start off with what I am grateful for
that's number one you are developing new
habits right now especially if you're at
home and the question I want to ask you
is are you developing empowering habits
or are you developing disempowering
habits a lot of people aren't
considering the fact that if you're at
home for two weeks four weeks six weeks
eight weeks your new patterns are being
created in your brain and if you repeat
any pattern for 30 days 60 days 90 days
and you reinforce it that pattern
becomes a habitual pattern so if you are
focusing on constructive patterns guess
what happens
you build constructive patterns in your
brain and that then drives all of your
thoughts emotions feelings sensations
and behaviors so if you just think that
you're on vacation right now at home
working for home and there's no effect
on that you are making a serious error
in your judgment now of all times is one
of the best times for you to be able to
focus on empowering patterns versus
disempowering patterns constructive ones
instead of destructive ones and positive
ones instead of disempowering ones after
I do my gratitude the very next thing
that I do is meditation every day every
day every day after I wake up I go and
sit and I meditate quietly I connect to
the source I connect to all of the
essence of life and I meditate either on
a problem that I have I want the
solution or I meditate on the global
situation I meditate by keeping my mind
quiet totally quiet as well and
eliminating all
and just tapping into the source of all
supply that's within me and all around
me all right so the question is do you
have empowering patterns or
disempowering patterns
most people don't focus on empowering
positive habits and they're wondering
you know why things are chaotic and
stressful you have to set up patterns
that are calm so you can respond instead
of stressful ones where you're reacting
all the time that's using the genius
part of your brain ok and so that is how
I start the first part of the morning
the other thing that I do is I have my
exceptional life blueprint with about 45
pages in it of all of my vision and my
goals and my life's mission my
intermission my our mission my
principles for an exceptional life my
core prayer every goal for health wealth
relationships career business every
single one of them is in my exceptional
life blueprint I review it every day I
prime my brain I listen to it because
I've recorded it I review it every
single day by going through it to prime
my brain to focus on what it is that I
want and then I use my goal cards and I
write out the three things that I am
going to do that day the three things
I'm going to get done that day why do I
do this why do I invest a little bit of
that time to get organized why because
if I am directing my brain my mindset my
emotions mice what my behaviors guess
who's going to thrive in these
challenging times versus who's just
going to survive or go backwards right
think about it if you are directing your
mindset on your emotions and your
behavior and you're focusing on how you
can thrive in this economy then guess
what's gonna happen you're gonna be
doing your morning routine makes the
difference between going through a day
of misery and fear and apathy or be
productive and serving and using this
time to lift your life
I mean in in the 5 a.m. Club there's the
the 20-20-20 formula it explains exactly
what to do between 5:00 and 6:00 to
battle proof your mind set to purify
your hearts to strengthen your health
set and to elevate your soul set what I
call the four interior empires in the
book but for now I'll just simply say
the way you begin your day right now is
going to dramatically affect the way
your day unfolds so start it with some
exercise so you release BDNF dopamine
which makes you feel better serotonin
which makes you feel better and you know
reduces the cortisol the fear hormone
start your day with exercise which will
release norepinephrine which will allow
greater focus in your mind so we'll BDNF
now if you're at home you can say I
can't get to the gym jumping jacks
skipping running on the spot push-ups
burpees you can do it in any room even
if you're in one room that'll release
BDNF which accelerates the brain and
focus so meditation exercise 3
journaling journaling will allow you to
process through do it early in the
morning because like that's the morning
routine when you journal you can release
your fear you can release the emotions
of loneliness or and put them on a page
which allows you to feel much more free
so you can focus and and I think those
are three specific tactics that allow
you to start your your day better final
thing I'd say is prayer prayer works
very well for me even 3 or 4 minutes to
lock you into your highest largest self
is powerful don't start your day
checking the news or your email or
social media or whatever
give yourself what would I call into 5
a.m. club your victory hour give
yourself an hour while the rest of the
world is asleep and it's never been so
asleep as now and an experience what you
and I know is
the most tranquil magical part of the
day and like even just looking at the
sunrise or taking the time to think
which we didn't do in early March for a
lot of the world and that will set the
tone for the day that you get that
becomes a through-line for the rest of
the day the advice is gonna sound really
repetitive because it's what works you
may have to have a routine yeah period
you have to create a routine and I'm
gonna take you to create your routine
that works for you during this moment I
[Music]
15 minutes mmm is it seriously
like we don't have to overcomplicate
this stuff you need a wake-up time right
you need to exercise because your body
stores tension you got to move that out
of there mm-hmm and you don't have an
excuse anymore
you're not going anywhere Rand if you're
watching this I know that you have
access to watch free videos that are
getting streamed online there's so many
people out there doing free classes get
your ass on one and move your body you
need to eat healthy you need to set a
quitting time for when you're done
working you need to turn the damn news
off I will tell you what the news is
gonna sound like from now until
September 1
people are dying you need to stay inside
goodbye that's it that's it right there
hand yeah
that's it there's no reason to turn on
this negativity and so and then you need
to have a bedtime that's your routine
period that's all you need and so what I
noticed is you know I didn't exercise
first thing this morning which I
normally do and that already made me go
like okay something's off
so you just need a routine do I have any
tips for starting the day positively in
this coronavirus situation like every
day I do and take the cold shower I take
the cold shower which wakes me up and
then I want to go everywhere because I
got so much energy No
I go into breathing breathing exercises
and from the breathing exercises which
tilts my mind in the deep I'm suddenly
aware and just being there being here
amazing feeling that's the way to start
the day eventually a push-up exercise
after doing 30 breaths is an amazing
jolt of adrenaline rushing through you
then you are able to start into any
other way because you have still your
mind and you have still to body through
the cold shower the breathing exercises
and the push-ups exercise you're really
on from there we can go anywhere this is
the way I start my day every day if you
want more advice wisdom guidance from
other successful entrepreneurs on how
you can navigate the coronavirus
situation check out the video right
there next to me I hope you find it
valuable and continue to believe and
I'll see you there
I would say that I received commentary I
get some commentary monthly